- So, what was your relationship
like with your mom? Like growing up?
Were you one of those kids
that did slime in the dog's hair?
- My mom let me do quite a bit of things
but my mom also had a
radical sense of humor.
Like an incredible sense of humor.
Like she, I remember she
knows I love animals.
So when I was in college,
she sent me a box that
had holes punched in it.
She, and in college,
and she said, I found you a pet.
You could, in the mail,
you could keep in your dorm room.
I hope it survived on the food and water.
And it was a dead lizard,
(audience laugh)
that she had found in the backyard
and was like this'll be funny
to send to my daughter.
(audience laughing)
- What?
- But she also once bought me
a taxidermied alligator
from, like a garage sale
(audience laughing)
and sent it to me in the mail.
- [Kelly] I love it.
- And she would go around
- This kind of explains how you
found your partner in life as well.
- A little bit, a little bit.
(Kelly laughs)
She would, I got two more zeros for you.
She would go around the neighborhood
and collect cicada
shells, you know, cicadas.
She, but she would put
them in a cookie tin
and then send 'em to me in college
and be like Christmas cookies
but it was just dead cicada shells.
(audience laughing)
- What?
- [Guest] And one time
when I was in high school,
- What?
- she bribed, she was
a cardiologist nurse,
she bribed like the mortician
to let her borrow three human hearts
and brought 'em into my science class.
- Pretty sure that's illegal.
(Kelly laughs)
Pretty sure that, I dunno.
- Well, if you can prove it, Kelly
because I had nothing to do with it.
- That, your mother is awesome.
- She's rad.
- Oh my God.
- She's got like a dark sense of humor,
which is probably where I get my
dark sense of humor.
- Oh my gosh.
And your attraction to it.
- Yeah.
- Oh my God. That's amazing.
I, I love your mom.